what can you tell the audience about
this case of annalise michelle
well are people familiar with the case
so it's uh assume they're not assume
none of us are
so they the premises so this is a uh a
lady in germany
who was uh determined to be possessed
she was working with a priest
and then she never did receive complete
deliverance
from the demonic oppression and then she
eventually died
at 23 years old she died and first she
started experiencing this at 16 years
old
and she would go to six different voices
she would make right it's neru
kane judas hitler fleischmann i'm
missing one
lucifer and each voice sounds different
and then eventually i mean you look at
her right now i want you to watch this i
want to get your reaction on this this
is right here and at least michelle
who if you listen to her voice sounds
like a regular voice speaking in german
if you want to play so the audience can
hear it
because they think
very normal
okay very normal fast forward to now
what she uh yeah go right there so this
is this is hitler
[Music]
i hope you're not watching this late at
night if you are
here's kane
[Applause]
very disturbing okay go to the next one
this is nero
this is fleischmann
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
go to the next one
[Music]
is
okay you can pause it at this point i
said it's going to be disturbing i got
to leave
no but but you but you know what though
here's the part so
first of all i feel bad for this girl
she passed away 23 years old okay you're
talking about somebody the mother that's
the mother standing right next to her i
mean they made a movie about this this
turned into a story that people watched
and
you know uh uh
you know you
even even if you try like yesterday
vinnie who's outside who doesn't like
vinnie got a shout out on this
but uh vinnie i said try making this
sound naturally
like if you really try to yourself make
this sound naturally go go try to do it
how does somebody do it naturally right
okay you may say i know certain people
that could do it
but this is a little strange adam you
can make a crazy advice like there's
people who they can do
but
it's not that hard to do part the part
he says the part he says
where it's those four signs yeah
unbelievable
out of nowhere power
that comes in okay like you know
somebody on pcp i don't know if you've
seen somebody on pcp yeah they can lift
the car up they can lift excess so
that's that part the other part is
language spoken that you don't speak
okay yeah and then third one is saying
information and things that you
shouldn't know those those
those two maybe not the first one but
those two
it's a little so when you see that have
you ever personally witnessed somebody
like that
oh yeah i've seen all those things all
the time you're being serious you've
seen that day in the life
well and because of the number of people
that contact me
that it would be
yeah an ordinary part i mean i have no
other exorcists
who say they've never dealt with a case
of possession in the years that they've
been an exorcist
but some of them some of us are publicly
known that some choose to remain
anonymous and those who are publicly
known we do receive a higher volume of
people who reach out to us
what's the key to success of the ones
that are successful and someone has
deliverance and can go live a
a life where they've you know replaced
it with you know this belief in christ
and now they're able to live free
what's the key to the success when
you've gone through your
you know your filters that you've
described
what's that key
is there a key is there something common
to the people that
now live free
i think there is first of all i would
say that
you know often oftentimes people that
suffer are suffering alone they're in
isolation
so bringing them back into a sense of
community helping people
reconnect with family and friends
another probably the biggest one is
helping people
connect with god in their life because
again it's not just a matter of casting
the evil out i've said that before i
can't say it enough it's about helping
people develop
an authentic relationship with god
you know makes me think of the stair the
story of the garrison demoniac in
chapter five of mark's gospel that you
know the man who's possessed by legion
he's living in the tombs
you know shackles won't even hold him
there's the superhuman strength
he's possessed by legion
jesus casts the demons out
they go into the swine the demons show
their true character they destroy the
swine they race over the hillside they
drown in the lake most people when
they're reading that biblical account
will stop reading at that point but i
would suggest the most important thing
happens next
the man who's now free wants to follow
jesus and jesus says no now how often in
the bible does jesus tell somebody not
to follow him
what does jesus say to him no go home to
your family so jesus takes someone who
was living amongst the dead in the tombs
and places them back amongst the living
with his family
so again creating healthy
relationships
is one of the ways that evil can be
defeated so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]